Hey, everyone.
We're gonna be taking a look at a few questions that relate ...
to the chapter two material and the learning objectives ...
that go with chapter two.
Let's go ahead and jump into it.
Our first question says a buyer is willing to pay $75 for ...
a product and a seller is willing to accept 45.
If the final sale price is $60, what is the total surplus generated?
So we have a $75 willingness to pay,
a $45 willingness to sell, and we sell it at $60.
So that is $15 in consumer surplus.
And this is also $15 in producer surplus.
So C will be our answer.
Just combine the 2:15 to get 30 as our total surplus.
So in this case, both of the parties are willing ...
to engage in trade because the $60 lies between the ...
willingness to pay and the willingness to sell.
Go to our next question.
A buyer values a car, a used car,
at $12,000, and the seller is willing to ...
accept $10,000.
So we have a willingness to pay of $12,000.
We have a willingness to sell of $10,000.
What is the maximum tax that can be added before the ...
transaction no longer occurs?
Well, that's pretty simple.
All we have to do is just figure out at what point does ...
the buyer no longer want to particip market.
And we see that 12,000 is going to be that number.
The seller is not going to be willing to accept anything ...
less than 10,000.
So that means all we need to do is just add up some ...
numbers here to the 10,000 to get something above 12,000.
What we see is A is actually going to be the answer.
We can only add up to $2,000 in taxes to reach the ...
maximum willingness to pay for that buyer.
B would still generate some surplus.
C and D are not going to work because they are way ...
beyond the willingness to pay.
So A is what we are looking for because we're looking for ...
where it no longer occurs.
That is, how much can we add before ...
it no longer occurs?
All right, question three here.
How does economic efficiency help a business ...
succeed in a marketplace?
Now, when we talk about economic ...
efficiency, what we are talking about is ...
trying to get the most bang for your buck to minimize ...
your cost, those types of things.
So what we are really saying is we are trying to allocate ...
our resources where they generate the most value.
That is, we're trying to minimize our ...
costs, maximize our profits,
trying to figure out a way to get the most value out of what we have.
So that's why A is going to be our answer.
Increases overall demand for Unrelated goods doesn't ...
really make sense for this question as an answer.
Guarantees higher profits regardless of market conditions.
That's not what we're talking about with economic ...
efficiency when we talk about market conditions and things like that.
Helps firms avoid interaction with government regulation.
No, that's just.
That's just nonsense.
All right, next question.
The market equilibrium rent for an apartment is $1,200 per month.
The city imposes a price ceiling of $900.
What is the likely result?
Now, whenever you have a price ...
ceiling, what you see is a situation in ...
which the quantity demand is going to be greater than ...
quantity supplied.
I mean, that should make sense.
$900 as rent now compared to the $1,200 what it used to be.
So what we should see with quantity demand being ...
greater than quantity supplied is a shortage take place.
That is assuming that this is a binding price ceiling.
So let's write that in here.
Binding price ceiling.
And these occur whenever the new price is below the ...
previous equilibrium price, which this is the case.
So let's go in here.
A shortage.  Yeah, there we go.
So a B is our answer.
A shortage as demand exceeds supply.
So if our quantity demand happened to be something ...
like 1000 at $900 and our quantity supplied happened ...
to be something like 600 at $900,
then we could clearly see that there is a shortage of ...
400 apartments per month there simply because of that ...
price ceiling being imposed, that binding price ceiling being imposed.
All right, let's move on to our next question.
The government sets a price floor of $15 for wheat,
even though the market price is $10.
What is the most likely outcome?
Now we're dealing with a price floor for binding price ...
floors. Let's write that in here.
Binding price floor.
For that to be a thing.
Let me actually write floor, not floor.
For a binding price floor to be a thing,
the price floor itself has to be greater than the market ...
equilibri mp whatever that stands for,
their market equilibrium price.
So in this case, the $15 is greater than the $10.
And we do have a binding price floor.
Now, what happens with a binding ...
price floor is the quantity supplied is greater than the ...
quantity demand.
In this case, the producers are willing to ...
sell more at that higher price than they were at that lower ...
market equilibrium price.
So whenever your quantity supplied is greater than your ...
quantity demand, what you're going to get is a surplus.
All right?  You're going to get a surplus.
So in this case, A does not work.
B does not work.
That decrease in wheat production wouldn't take ...
Place it actually would have an increase in wheat production.
No change in quantity supplied.
Well, we know that's not going to ...
happen because people want to sell more at that higher ...
price than at that price, previous equilibrium price,
which means D, a surplus as farmers produce ...
more that consumers buy is going to occur because of ...
that new binding price floor of $15.
All right, let's move on to our next question.
Which scenario best represents a money making ...
opportunity through voluntary trade?
Money making opportunity through voluntary trade.
So we are trying to generate surplus.  Okay.
Firm shuts down production due to excess supply.  Nope.
A city bans short term rentals like Airbus.
That doesn't generate surplus.
A seller values are good at $60 and a buyer is willing to pay $100.
That does generate surplus.
Company stores unused inventory indefinitely.
Well, that's not allocating ...
resources to their best use.
So definitely not that either.
So that is why C is going to be our answer.
Because it generates surplus where the others do not.
All right, our last question.
How does the structure of an organization influence its ...
ability to create wealth?
All right, so let's look at each of these answers.
It determines how profits are distributed at the end of the year.
I mean, determining how profits are ...
going to be distributed is important,
but that doesn't tell you about the structure and ...
influencing on its ability to create wealth.
So I mean, here you're just determining ...
the wealth and how it's distributed,
not how it's created.
All right, it affects how well incentives ...
align with wealth creating decisions.
I mean, this is obviously going to be ...
our answer because here we are,
we have an organization, a structure inside of our ...
organization that determines how we generate that wealth.
How we create that that wealth,
which means that C and D are not going to be answers,
guarantees that no bad decisions will ever be made.
Well, that's not even true at all.
And it allows firms to ignore customer preferences.
That wouldn't be actually in the best interest of the firm to do so.
That is why B is going to be our answer.
Because it aligns the structure of the organization ...
with the ability to generate wealth.
All right, that is it for our work.
Problems coming out of chapter two.
Hope you have enjoyed it.